and I will tell you one thing that I
learned from 20 years of experience in
food industry taste is before everything
to the consumer so if nothing is not if
if a food is not tasty nobody will touch
it that's it and therefore this is the
struggle of the food
[Music]
companies BOS noi welcome to 20 minute
leaders I'm so excited to have you here
how are you I'm fine thank you for
having me I'm feeling quite good well
you you must be feeling good because
you're having a alternative proteins H
with next firm and and I'm so excited to
dive into this whole world of
alternative proteins vegan food food
Tech in general and and so H take me
already to to where we're at today so
what what is sort of the space that
we're that we're talking about that that
you're living in so in a simple way when
you're going into the supermarket not
only in Israel all around the world you
would notice that the growing shelf is
the shelf of alternative meaning food
that is vegan this is like the nice word
for vegan is alternative H this is the
most growing segment in the food sector
and this is the most profitable area for
the food manufacturers and this is not
this is for a reason due to the fact
that the there are three main reasons
for it first is
sustainability ER that all animal
derived food creates a lot of um I would
say harm to our planet and this is very
well known this is one very important
reason that people are becoming vegan
trivial because a lot of times people
think that a that that a lot of vegans
are because of animals but it actually
turns out that a lot of them are because
of the impact that that the meat
industry has and the dairy industry has
on our world right and our on our
climate and our ecosystem so so this is
for for me it's the main reason
but it depends because some people are
vegan because of Mercy to
animals and are many and today in the
internet um I would say area you can
find very easily H what any animal to to
to to what how animal are suffering in
order that we can eat them how they are
being raised in what conditions and it's
a very big issue and I will tell you the
truth only after becoming vegan I open
my mind to look into it but today it
became a very important reason for me to
remain V again because now when I see
track with animals understand exactly
what they experience in order that we
can eat properly animal the right food
as human so this is another reason for
people to avoid eating animals or animal
products so this is the second reason
the the third reason of course there is
the like the moral issue with the
animals and the
sustainability but the health issue is
another issue because even little
children when they're going to doctors
and suffering from all kind of disease
they say if you can avoid if you can
avoid milk derived products for a while
your child will be will feel much better
this is a very big issue and a lot of
people the the connection between dairy
products and and and and like breathing
normally and the asthma and the
connection between asthma to this and
the connection between Cancer to eating
the animal so there are a lot of um I
would
say Publications that speak about the
connection between eating animal derived
products and all kind of illness I
wouldn't get into the the reality
whether what is true and what is causing
what but this is what people are feeling
and and this is what drive people these
are the three reason that drive people
into becoming vegan and want to avoid as
much as or flexitarians meaning to eat
less of animal derived products or at
least to replace some of it so this is
the main reason from consumer point of
view so the world is is changing in food
Tech we're talking about vegan and
alternative food um and and if what
started off is a lot just you know logic
before now is becoming a big big market
and then we keep seeing it around and
there's a lot of different things to do
in this in this market in food Tech and
in veganism an alternative food
particularly what are you doing with
with next firm firm and what what is
really that your
what is the real you know problem that
you're solving here so to become vegan
meaning to eat vegetables not eat
anything that's coming out of animals or
that deriv from animals and when you
when you look into the Shelf you will
find a lot of alternative products but
the replacement for milk will not have
the proper protein inside protein is a
real real issue yes to build the muscles
it's a big issue and in most alternative
product there's a lot of compromise
compromising in nutrition values and
also in taste because today in the Shelf
you will find a lot of alternative
products using all kind of plant in
order to create these products now the
plants are a having less nutrition value
as protein comparing to animal derived
proteins this is one thing to understand
B there are less
digestable to our body this is another
very important issue and see if you are
taking a PL derived protein powder for
example from PE or from CHP in most
cases it will to bring with it the taste
of the plant in some combinations of
food it will work properly in others it
won't and I will tell you one thing that
I learned from 20 years of experience in
food industry taste is before everything
to the con so if nothing is not if if a
food is not tasty nobody will touch it
that's it and therefore this is the
struggle of the food companies a to
bring very tasty food and B to to to H
keep it nutrition enough and to keep
your nutrition in a high level if you'll
take for example cheese industry protein
I would say alternative cheese and you
look at the labeling in many cases
you'll find that the protein levels are
very very low the same with milk and and
many other product and even if you have
the same amount of grams like hamburgers
which are vegan you will find that they
have 20 grams but not always all the
amino acid not always in the same
digestability and the amino acid
composition is dramatically decreased
comparing to meat itself as as a protein
so there's a lot of challenges in this
industry now what next firm actually
conducted we developed yeast D protein d
from yeast yeast is a microorganism
known to us to living in bread or to
create alcohol and because it's
microorganism the protein inside it is
very similar in the amino acid
composition and digestability to what we
are having from animal derived products
so taking out the protein is a having
the same
nutrition the technology of NEX firm
enabled us to do it in a very neutral
taste and this is the second most
important thing or the first main
important thing because if a company
would like to have an alternative cheese
they would like it to feel like cheese
they would like it with no different
taste that they they will have to flavor
in order to take it out so this is the
main the main issue about proteine we
call it the only protein with anyal like
nutritional value and neutral taste and
this combination is almost not exist in
the market today is so interesting first
looking back to the consumer Behavior
and the distinction that with all the
rationale our world is going you know
our world is collapsing into climate
change and animals are suffering and all
the ethics around it and you feel better
not is if you if you hurt The Taste
people go back to the old ways of being
which makes sense it's and and and it's
so intuitive because you know you see it
in every other industry you see it in
the Cyber industry you see it in the
e-commerce industry ultimately it's
about fr less experiences and how do you
make it more accessible and and it
sounds like you're tackling this problem
from the from the biology of it right
from the root of it how do you fit into
this sort of ecosystem of food Tech
where where does your product live in
the stack who do you who do you
integrate the product into who do you
sell it to so actually a a next firm is
developing is a B2B company meaning
business to business we are selling the
powder of a concentrated protein derived
from yeast
with a neutral taste and animal like
nutritional value as mentioned and we
sell it to food companies now there our
our powder can integrate to many many
products it will not always give the the
the whole solution but it gives the
protein into it and does not influence
the taste so if for example we are
selling to a a dairy company that would
like to have an alternative milk or
alternative cheese they can put our part
into their product in a way that it will
be very tasty vegan and with nutritional
value like real Dairy if you are taking
the one of the most known products of
alternative meaning old milk any coffee
bar will have it ER almost all all
around the world but still it's like
water with taste it's a little bit of
gluten inside which is a very low rank
protein very n digestible and it have
like third of them amount comparing to
milk our powder can fortify this oat
milk and actually provide you the same
Good Taste of oat milk with the
nutritional value like real milk so this
is kind of a a how to make a product
that everybody known and love and this
is the one of the most growing brands
for many companies and make it something
better where next room is today we just
started like we launch several product
and our first low hanging fruits is
protein powders for sports nutritional
it cause well-being we are selling for
powders for sports which is where are
like 85 to 90% of the product is our
protein they add some taste like
chocolate caca and and all kind of
sachets with
taste and getting the product so this is
the first lwh hanging fruits but we are
already working with food companies we
had the first launch in Europe in
Belgium of spread replacement it's it's
like egg
replacement spread and and we have
excellent we call it application it's
like food demonstration cheese cream
cheese we got compliments from the
biggest companies in the world producing
cheese and I would say that food
companies it takes them more time to
evaluate and integrate new ingredients
into the line of products but we are
very progress with that just H this
month we open our first line of product
ction in
India we are you are sitting on the
source of the yeast meaning the raw
material which is sugar actually you you
you are develop you are producing the
yeast from
Sugar Sugar can or corn wherever and
then you take the glucose make yeast out
of it and we are like in a zero waste
process we are getting out the protein
and two AR by products yeast extract
which is the Taste in all the vegan
products and sell walls which is like
fibers that you can provide for animals
and you can take better glucan out of it
so this is the whole process so we are
just starting now in the production in
big scales and growing scale a lot of
customers are waiting for to launch a a
a products that are based on our protein
and this is super exciting and bz bottom
line question does it taste better of
course this is tricky question because
how mission is to be as tasteless as
possible so the the food producers are
adding The Taste God so the distinction
is that what happens with let's just
look at the protein power which is a
huge Market I know and I've I've tested
myself a bunch of of of alternative
proteins um during times in which I was
practicing more veganism but and it
sounds like what you're saying that the
big part of the problem is that as you
transition to alternate and protein
sources you're effectively
introducing bad taste which is leftovers
from the plants which is what you said
before and you're effectively trying to
back to neutralize it so that then you
can just enjoy the the pure Taste of
vanilla cow chocolate Etc BOS tell me a
little bit about yourself so how did you
get wrapped into this world and how did
you discover this why are you so
passionate about this you know my
background is financial it's very funny
I I I I have certificate public
accountant and I'm opposite of it for
many many years I started at a company
called enzy Tech it's a foodtech company
and and I had a great journey I became a
a a the senior VP and the head of the
nutrition division we developed
ingredients into the water's nutrition
after taking the company into the NASDAQ
I left the company and then a few months
afterwards I started to I I got into
another fotte company and we didn't deal
at the beginning with protein at all we
started with other ingredients that
derive from yeast that related to East
because East is the main technology our
company is developing developing
products that are derived from yeast we
are improving the strands themselves in
a nmo way everything neutral and we are
doing a lot of extraction a purification
to get materials without any taste and
when we bump into previous customers of
us in the market they told us guys you
are the guys from enzotech
and you are playing with yeast why won't
you make protein out of it this is the
most biggest thing we s you know they
are right about it and this is how it
starts but after I I I jumped into the
subject and started to learn it myself I
I I I fell in love and became vegan
myself and since then for several years
I'm I'm already vegan I didn't touch
anything perhaps without knowing I have
funny stories of course you know you
don't always know ER
but but I jumped into the subject and
decide for myself it's great and and I
was a great carival before I ate a lot
of meat and eggs and and dairy products
without any problem and all of a sudden
it goes from 100 to zero and and my body
like it I feel much better I feel
healthier and I don't miss anything and
of course I would like to have more
products which are vegan and and today
you eating sometimes more carbs that you
would like to have as a vegan because
the solutions are not full are not are
not f are not are not 100% as
mentioned but but but it's Israel is
like an a heaven for a for vegan a lot
of products here a lot of innovation and
it's not very hard to be vegan in Israel
wow I think that that's a that those are
all amazing reasons to for why you're
doing what you're doing tell me about
the future what what what is what is in
store for us you know if you think even
three four five years down the line what
is the future for the world of veganism
what is the future for our next firm for
alter alternative proteins in general
you know according to Boston Consulting
Group ER they they they they published a
year ago something like that that until
2035 which is not very far far 10% of
the products derived from animal will be
will become vegan 90 will stay will
remain this is like
um I'm talking about 300 billion dollar
market so if you are calculating it's
like a gross of 20% per year H so in
this industry most people will remain
carnivors but more and more people will
became um
flexitarians H will change small parts
in their diet like in many countries in
Germany they have like a a vegan Monday
or this kind of things that they one day
they are not eating animal direct
products or they are replacing their
milk or they are replacing meal or
whatever but every such a things create
an another percentage in this equation
and I believe that is there a future in
which everybody's vegan I don't know
because food is like is like a religion
for some people and to be honest with
you
um I don't believe in
very there will be a reduction but as
long as the world is growing more and
more people will have to be vegal
because you cannot feed the entire world
with with with cows and with pigs and
with
animals and therefore um it's like step
by step more products which are vegan
and good will create people easier
transformation this is one issue a a a
more regulation to avoid to grow animals
because it's harmed environment will
create more solutions and higher price
for animal derived products so this like
this uh role of a Evolution for this
industry will create a change I I'm not
sure that it a short short like 10 years
it can take 50 years or 100 years but in
one years I believe that veganism will
be the most in 10 years or 20 years even
if it will be 10 or 20% it's huge huge
huge unbelievable growing market for for
company like us I hope that more people
will become vegan for the planet for the
animals for their health but I'm not
preaching for anybody my family and my
wife became vegan with me and my kids
are doing whatever they want so and I'm
cooking them whatever they want I'm not
a radical on this issue and I'm going to
any restaurant in any place I can find
things for myself so everybody has his
own choices and it's okay and even to
choose to replace one meal is great in
my eyes was thank you so much for
joining me this is such an awesome space
that you're in such a cool company and
and cool personal story so thank you for
providing this inspiration from me over
these 20 minutes and and I think that
everybody that's uh that's tuned into
this is also very much appreciative of
it so thank you very very much best of
luck thank you appreciate it I felt it
was one minute I felt it too thank you
so much thank you so much have a great
day